donc vous avez été nommé non pas nominé
comme mondiale a soit meilleure actrice
pour les césars mais en plus vous
présenter la soirée
oui je suis maîtresse de cérémonie
maîtresse de cérémonie m6 valérie voilà
est votre mission c'est de faire oublier
gad elmaleh qui était excellent c'est
pas de faire oublier ses deux lui
succède et et la barre est haute
ouais je cherche pas le faire oui moi je
les regarde je suis sur cette formidable
enjeu pas du tout inquiet si ba oui je
suis un peu mais non je veux un pouvoir
comique z et fanny bones comme on dit
vous êtes drôle donc c'est sûr ça va
être bien quoique vous fassiez les gens
vous préparez un peu non évidemment
ohlala on va continuer la préparation on
va faire une interview au coaching césar
bay qu'est-ce que vous porterez comme
tenue très jolie robe
oui emporter ou en anorak
si on vous interview avant est ce que
vous allez dire que vous espérez la
boire mais qu'avant tout c'est un grand
honneur d'être nommé
j'espère surtout qu'on a interviewé
avant à ce moment là je pourrai d'accord
sûr et qu'il avait accepté de présenter
parce que vouliez pas rester assise
pendant trois heures c'est vrai j'aime
bien debout en général d'ailleurs je
peux 7 me mettre debout pour défendre m
apprenez à brest debout ferais comment
ferez vous fais comment pour le standing
ovation vous vous levez c'est à dire que
je ne serai pas dans la fac je serai sur
scène j'ai de beaux donc je serais déjà
de bouchons à vous toute la soirée il
vous serez dans la salle au moment où y
ait forcément ice est prévu comme ça ben
je sais pas olala salaires organisée
c'est très clair alors imaginons ben
c'est l'heure des nominations meilleure
actrice
on dit les nominations meilleure actrice
donc pendant que les deux crétins qui
vont nous remplacer sur scène par lequel
peut-être vous faites c'est très
important que c'est l'écran est coupée
en quatre et là on voit juste après les
deux crétins sur scène à vous êtes tous
mais oui donc c'est votre année on la
voit pas pendant trois ans alors après
disons oui quelle tête vous ferez non
vous souriez pendant ce moment là de
voir à wii fit et le césar de la
meilleure actrice est d'attribuer à
valérie lemercier beaucoup
c'est normal
que c est
quand vous avez sur scène vous dit
pardon pardon comme ça comme s'ils ont
tous à vos yeux
pardon pardon avec l'europe mais je
serai sur scène fait semblant de tomber
de façon à ce que vous soyez dans les
bêtisiers dans les 20 prochaines années
oui oui vous faites nous des trucs pour
les bêtisiers parce qu'il ya des gens à
la télé qui vivent de ça mais on va
faire un bêtisier avant même que vous
pleurez à ce moment là si vous l'avez
écouté et je n'ai pas pleuré depuis
l'âge de 18 ans n'ont donc vous avez
pleuré pour souvent sinon donc j'ai pas
commencé samedi prochain vous pleurez
monseigneur vous ça m'arrive à envoyer
au cinéma aussi que tu pleures et non
cela m'est arrivé ces derniers temps bah
oui oui avec célia fans de guillaume
célia vous remercier qui en premier vous
direz c'est avant tout le travail d'une
équipe une rencontre avec un réalisateur
oui sûrement vu que c'est vous le
réalisateur non mais je remercierai
c'est vrai que j'ai eu à faire un très
très grand réalisateur est une femme
formidable
vous allez remercier la grande famille
du cinéma français veulent vraiment faut
il penser à ça 1 vous féliciterez les
trois filles qui ont perdu quand même
bien sûr surtout qu'elles sont pas mal
non plus les autres
ah bon vous oubliez votre césar sur
scène histoire de faire le giro
non non non ah les intermittents du
spectacle j'y penserai oui oui un petit
mot oui il ya un petit bout vous mettrez
un bonnet péruvien cela
et si vous perdez alors qu'elle tentait
de voir la tête que vous allez faire un
malheur et si vous perdez vous êtes bien
non
mais parce que je veux pas la voir
pourquoi vous avez pas si vous allez
voir tous les gens qui présentent les
césar n'ont jamais sont quand ils sont
nommés et non pas deux minutes -
c'est-à-dire gad elmaleh antoine de
caunes edouard baer voilà ne l'ont
jamais bien sûr que l'horreur mais c'est
comme ça annulée mais non je préfère les
présents bon alors allez c'est bon livre
ont atteint leur mettre votre césar est
ce que vous appelez yvan à table avant
de l'embrasser
non je dis
dalé
le case